on soir samedi avec tout merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france ça y
est on y est trois mois et demi après
son ouverture le procès touche à sa fin
quel bilan peut-on en faire avant le
délibéré dans quel état d'esprit êtes
vous écoutez d'abord comme ça a été
rappelé par l'ensemble des partis
c'était un procès éprouvant lent mais il
a eu le mérite de se tenir c'est
extrêmement important que ce procès
qualifié d'historique et pu se tenir
il a pu se tout se tenir dans le respect
de notre état de droit dans le respect
des des droits des accusés la cour
vous l'avez rappelé il s'agit d'une cour
constituée de magistrats professionnels
elle a permis à l'ensemble des accusés
de se prononcer 2 il y a eu un débat
ouvert un débat qui a permis à
l'ensemble des accusés de d'exposer leur
point de vue il ya eu un débat clair
utile de steam pour la vérité et il y a
aussi eu ces interruptions qui témoigne
du respect scrupuleux de l'état du droit
et de du procès équitable puisque ces
suspensions correspondait justement un
état de fatigue de maladie d'un des
accusés
et c'était un moment fort de ce procès
où les parties civiles se sont jointes à
la aux avocats de la défense pour dire
nous refusons que l'accusé malade en
plus qui risque la perpétuité
la halle à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité puissent être présents à la
salle d'audience pour entendre les
plaidoiries de la partie civile
d'entendre le réquisitoire est de
pouvoir
s'expliquer s'exprimer puisque la parole
appartient en dernier à l'accusé on
voulait pour respecter les normes du
procès équitable que cette dernière
parole soit éclairé par tout ce qu'il
aura entendu non pas à travers une
visioconférence comme le décret dernière
minute avaient été pendus pour que cette
cour poursuivre ses activités et sont
les débats eh bien nous sommes nous
avons été satisfaits du fait que la
visioconférence a été écarté par le
conseil d'état et cela est un
soulagement parce que ça consacre une
fois de plus le principe du procès
équitable et du respect deux des accusés
qui étaient là pour une manifestation
ultime de la vérité 2pour en présence
des victimes d'ailleurs samia maktouf
évidemment c'est ce qu'espèrent tous les
proches des des victimes avoir des
débuts de réponse est ce que vous avez
le sentiment sur ce point là qu'il y a
une forme de soulagement on va dire de
début de réponse à l'impensable
finalement à l'inexplicable pour eux
certainement écouté je ne pourrais pas
m'aventurer à vous dire qu'il y a eu des
réponses
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
ce procès a eu le mérite de se tenir
les victimes étaient là parce qu'elle
voulait entendre elle voulait voir elle
voulait des réponses
malheureusement des zones d'ombré
demeurent il faut reconnaître que il ya
des angles morts il faut reconnaître
qu'il y a des
des questions qui sont restées sans
réponse que malheureusement le procès
n'éclairera pas les victimes sur toutes
les circonstances de ce procès en
revanche ce procès s'est tenu ce procès
a eu lieu il y a eu un débat constructif
il a eu un délit a eu un débat qui a
permis aux victimes de suivre
les éléments et les explications de ces
accusés parce que c'est aussi ça un
procès équitable
donc oui même si le tout les un certain
nombre de questions demeurent en suspens
mais pour autant ce procès s'est tenu
pardonnez moi de le répéter c'est très
important que ce procès ait eu lieu
merci beaucoup m samia maktouf avocate
de familles de victimes d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france